Nick Jonas he just got a new wife only I
had a chance to talk to the newlywed
about his beautiful new bride Priyanka
Chopra my life is very good right now
I'm very excited lots of good things
coming up it's been a good year that my
friend is an understatement just a month
after the celeb wedding to end all
weddings the newlyweds rang in the New
Year with a kiss in the Swiss Alps also
on the itinerary during their whimsical
winter getaway quality time with the
in-laws holiday drinking games and lots
of PDA with Priyanka it was kind of an
instant thing knew once we locked in
together that I had a partner for life
and a teammate's and let him walk
through good times and bad times with
and that was the key I'm blushing now
and while the 26 year olds life seems
stress-free he's all about taking
preventative measures to keep it that
way
I'm a type 1 diabetic as well if the
importance of health in my life is is
everything and it starts with you know
the mind and the body
mix partnering with Sigma to encourage
fans to be open with their doctor about
everything they're feeling the body and
mind they're all connected and when you
can get a grasp on all that I think it's
really helpful
[Music]